so if bola virus is a very fragile
little virus that's quite difficult to
catch and very easy to stop with good
public health measures we think it comes
from animals now the first time it came
into humans was 38 years ago and that
was quite a bad outbreak and since then
it's been coming back about every two
years the symptoms you would have would
look a lot like the flu you'd have joint
pains a sore throat I mean this sounds
like almost any disease that you could
imagine later on it progresses to
horrible diarrhea and vomiting and
toward the end you get so weak that you
basically can't sit up there may be
blood leakage but usually that's on the
inside rather than the outside so what
the doctors in the region are doing is
they're essentially giving supportive
therapy with this with putting fluid
back into the person to replace what's
lost by diarrhea for example you can
actually improve the survival rate from
ninety percent fatal so ten percent
survival up to something like a 50-50
chance of living with each virus and
each kind of bacteria they're
biologically unique not just
biologically different but biologically
unconnected with the rest of the tree of
life at least all the viruses you have
to have one drug that exactly fits Ebola
the other problem on top of that is that
one drug usually isn't enough to stop
these because viruses are very good at
growing and very good at changing so
it's not just one drug that we need for
Ebola we need a cocktail of drugs and
perhaps a nice vaccine that could be
used these all take a lot of money and
right now in the history of what we know
at least there have been fewer than
5,000 people who have been infected with
Ebola it sounds scary but I don't know
that there's enough panic or enough
people who are potential customers for
these drugs to warrant a company a
private company anyway putting the money
and it would take to develop these